are you looking for some extra private
pilot study material
you're in the right place because today
on free pilot training we're going to be
studying class
c air space here's a quick overview of
what we're going to be talking about
today
and as you can see this lesson is jam
packed full of information
i'm even going to touch on radio
communications which is often one of the
hardest parts of becoming a private
pilot
so let's get started by taking a quick
look at some of the characteristics of
class charlie airspace
the first thing you'll notice about
class charlie is that it's similar to
class bravo in that it's also shaped
like an upside down wedding cake
because of this pilots can fly
underneath one of those shelves and
still stay out of the class c
airspace let's see how this would look
on a vfr
sectional you can identify class charlie
airspace
by these solid magenta rings surrounding
the airfield
every airfield with class charlie
airspace is a little different in some
way
but typically you'll see a five mile
ring surrounding the airfield that
starts at the surface and goes up to
4000 feet agl
then most of the time that outer ring is
a 10 mile radius from the airfield
the bottom of this airspace usually
starts at 1200 agl
and goes up to 4000 agl
you can find out the exact altitude of
this airspace by taking a look at the
vfr
sectional just like in class b airspace
we have these numbers that look like
they're improper fractions
these are the altitudes where our
airspace starts and where it ends
in this case the class c starts at 2 300
msl and goes up to 4700 msl
then on this inner ring you can see that
the top's also 4700 msl
but this one starts at the surface one
thing to keep in mind about class
charlie is that these outer rings can be
segmented
that just means the bottom of the air
space could start at a different
altitude
time for a quick quiz i'm flying inside
this outer ring
at 2 000 feet msl am i in the class c
airspace yet the answer is no the class
c starts at two thousand three hundred
here
i think you've got that down now let's
look at some of the rules you need to
know
first we need to establish two-way radio
communications with atc
prior to entry then we need to maintain
those communications while within the
airspace
unlike class bravo we only need to
establish two-way radio communications
we don't have to be clear to go into
class charlie airspace
let's take a look at how we can do that
by talking about the radio
communications
remember this format let's use it again
who they are
who you are where you are and what you
want
first things first you'll notice on the
vfr sectional that they want you to
contact the approach controllers within
20 nautical miles of the airfield
while this is not required this is to
help you out
atc needs time to find you on radar and
while you don't have to be clear to
enter class charlie airspace
they can tell you to avoid class charlie
until they find you on radar
and anytime we get instruction from atc
we need to comply with those
instructions
so do yourself a favor and contact them
once you get within 20 miles
okay so i'm flying my cessna 152 into
tulsa international airport
i'm 20 nautical miles to the northwest
at 3500
msl i just listened to the atus and
they're playing information tango
let's call them up real quick tulsa
approach
cessna 6789 x-ray 20 nautical miles to
the northwest
3500 with tango request straight in to
runway 1
8 left now remember the first thing we
need to go into this airspace is to
establish two-way radio communications
so we need to hear a full call sign back
if you hear aircraft calling and then
something else
you have an established two-way radio
communications yet
in this case we can't go into the class
charlie airspace yet
but as long as they read back our full
call sign we can go ahead and proceed
into the class charlie airspace unless
of course they specifically tell us not
to enter yet
even if you hear cessna 6789 x-ray
stand by you've still established
two-way radio communications
and they aren't specifically telling you
to avoid class charlie airspace
so you've met the requirements and now
you can come in
okay so let's say they called us back
cessna 6789
x-ray tulsa approach descend and
maintain 2500 squawk0223
now we've heard our full call sign so we
can go in now there's a couple things
that we need to do
we need to descend and maintain 2500 and
squawk 0-2-2-3
now just repeat the numbers and add your
call sign to the end so they know you
heard correctly
descend and maintain two thousand five
hundred squawk zero
two two three cessna six seven eight
nine x-ray
then once they find you on radar you
might hear something like this
cessna six 6789 x-ray radar contact
fly heading 180 make straight in for
runway one eight right
now it's always really important to pay
attention to what atc says because if
you remember
i asked for one eight left but they gave
me one eight right
now i could ask if they'll allow me to
change to 1 8 left
but it's really important to land on the
runway they tell you to
for today 1 8 writes better anyway so
i'll just call them back
heading 180 make straight in for runway
one eight right
cessna six seven eight nine x-ray then
once approach is ready to hand you off
to tower you'll hear cessna 6789
x-ray contact tower now 118.7
just repeat the frequency and your call
sign that's all they need to hear
118.7 cessna 6789 x-ray
once we switch frequencies let's give
them a quick call tulsa tower
cessna 6789 x-ray on a 5-mile straight
in for runway one eight right
today's an easy day you hear cessna 6789
x-ray clear to land runway 1-8 right
when it comes to landing clearances they
need to hear every bit of that
information back
so today i'm going to respond by saying
clear to land runway 1
8 right cessna 6789 xray
now let's take a look at the vfr weather
minimums for class charlie airspace
this is the worst weather you can have
and still be legal to fly
vfr first is three statute miles
visibility
that means we need to be able to see for
three miles
next we need to be able to stay away
from the clouds we need to stay at least
500 feet below the clouds
two thousand feet from the sides and a
thousand feet above
a really good memory aid for this is
or three 152s as in cessna 152s
if you can remember that you'll have the
numbers memorized you'll just have to
remember which ones go where
the last thing we'll talk about today is
the equipment required to fly
into class c airspace first is a working
two-way radio
remember we need two-way radio
communications to go into class c
airspace so that makes sense
next we need a working transponder with
mode c
that just means it reports our altitude
to air traffic control
when it comes to transponders they all
have to have mode c
capability in order to go into class
charlie
but in addition to that they also need
to be capable of 4096 which is mode 3a
or mode s you don't need to know what
these do
you just need to know that your
transponder needs to be capable of mode
c
and one of these one thing to keep in
mind is that if we stay below the class
c
shelf we don't need a transponder but
if we fly over the top of the class c
airspace we do need a transponder
by the way a huge thank you to bold
method for letting me use some of their
graphics
if you haven't been to their website be
sure and go check them out
they've got lots of different free study
material to help clarify some of these
subjects
i'll throw a link in the description if
you want to check that out
the last piece of equipment we need to
operate in class charlie is adsb
now while you really don't need to know
what it stands for you do need to know
that you need
adsb out this piece of equipment tells
atc your position through satellite
instead of radar
in class charlie airspace anywhere you
need a transponder you
also need adsb now as someone pointed
out in my last video
there are some exceptions to these adsb
requirements
if you think you qualify be sure to
check part 91-225
you want to be 100 certain that you meet
these exceptions before you go into
class charlie without
adsb because in most situations it is
required
hey before you get out of here today
make sure your thumb lands on top of
that like button for me
and if you haven't already be sure to
subscribe and hit the bell notification
so you don't miss out on more free pilot
training